so I can say that 20 years ago chess was
much more popular than poker and so if
poker made such progress so we cannot
deny that chest could make also progress
and became became popular as it was
before
cheese cheese can develop very important
characteristics individual
characteristics first of all chest
develops logic memory and then this
chest you can easily understand the
necessity of both plan and then you can
you can learn how to make to make
strategy which is important for for
normal life for any profession and
that's why just just as entering school
programs in many countries because
teachers realized that its help of chess
you can give this knowledge much easier
than with the help of other subjects
so this is the unique opportunities now
to to change to change the situation and
chess is in danger as profession and so
Federation which which is existing now
and leadership so they made many
mistakes and so now we have we have
feeling that professional chess chess
players have difficulties in financing
and such prices going down and then it's
difficult to do to keep this this
profession and internationally we have
very good situation now because we have
Grandmaster Magnus Carlsen from Norway
who is who is one of the best chess
players and most probably he will be he
will be next world champion and then we
have we have American player II
carbonate Kimura who is also on on the
top and then we have Sergei Kuryakin in
Russia then we have good players in
China in Holland in India and so it and
then Indian Grandmaster vision and he
just defended his title in match in
Sofia against Bulgarian player to follow
and so he he is world champion for many
years already and and then this is this
is very international of you that I'm
just from a time it was just privilege
of mostly solid players and later
Russian players but now it became very
international so it gives a lot of
opportunities and this opportunities
could be used with the new team and I
will have top professional team
representing of course the different
parts of the world